[Music]
we never envisioned four years ago a
global pandemic to accelerate the needs
and adoptions
by non-profits of digital solutions to
help them with their fundraising
in the first 12 weeks of covert 19 it
was estimated
that uk non-profits experienced a
shortfall in income of 4.3 billion
goodbox is here to change all that with
our hardware and software
we can help non-profits access the
latest in digital innovation at an
affordable cost
[Music]
[Music]
habu works by helping online sellers
ship their stuff to their buyers so if
you have you have a website and
you sell some items or you sell on ebay
or amazon or some other channel
you're going to have to pack those boxes
yourself we help you by taking that job
off your hands
so when the transactions come in when
you sell something on ebay or amazon
that automatically comes to us via our
systems and then one of our hub managers
picks packs and posts that item
on your behalf so that you don't have to
[Music]
ultra leap is the world's only
commercially available mid-air haptics
and ham tracking company
2020 has been a difficult year for most
businesses
instead of the business adopting a
defensive attitude towards the covet
situation
we pivoted the business and provided
solutions such as
touchless screens for fast food chains
touchless elevator buttons
and many other touchless solutions which
help to reduce the virus situation
and actually promote our business at the
same time
[Music]
verti uses virtual augmented reality
technology to transport users into
difficult to access clinical
environments
we mainly focus on soft skills based
training things that doctors nurses
clinicians have to go through already
and we either record them in 360 video
or we use
computer generated graphics to put those
into virtual environments where people
can then be assessed
we analyze some of the 360 video content
and we look specifically at how
the user and the learner is actually
interacting with
the decision-making process
[Music]
you